seguramente estás bastante familiarizado
con la idea de escalas lineales porque
es lo que has visto en clases y bueno de
hecho sería muy bueno recordar que son
las escalas lineales para darle paso a
algo nuevo así que vamos a ver qué es
una escala en dial si yo dibujo aquí un
eje numérico y aquí en medio tengo el
cero si yo me quiero mover hacia la
derecha 10 lo que estoy haciendo es un
mando 10 unidades hasta llegar del 0 al
10 pues llegaría al valor de 10 y si yo
sumo otras 10 unidades es decir me mueve
la derecha a otras 10 unidades llegaría
al valor de 20 y así no puedo continuar
moviendo 10 unidades es decir llegar 30
40 50 etcétera y los padres las escalas
lineales que también te puedes regresar
y te regresas del 10 al 0 vas a
disminuir 10 unidades es decir caminaría
hacia la izquierda y si caminas otras 10
unidades de la izquierda vas a restar 10
unidades llegaríamos al menos 10 al
menos 20 y así etc etc
además las escalas lineales tienen una
propiedad bien padre que si yo quisiera
recorrer la mitad del camino es decir en
lugar de recordar 10 unidades
que recorre la mitad pero me podría
fijar en 10 y multiplicarlo por un medio
o la mitad de 10 es decir me tomaría 5
unidades porque la mitad de 10 son 5
unidades y entonces tengo que caminar la
mitad del camino déjame ponerlo aquí si
yo lo que quiero es caminar del 0 a la
derecha en la mitad del camino de 10
unidades llegaría al valor de 5 lo cual
es la mitad de la distancia y déjame
dibujarlo aquí supongamos que de aquí a
camps es el valor de 5 y de igual manera
acción que ir hacia atrás cinco unidades
llegaría el valor de menos 5 es más
déjame ponerlo un poco más centrado para
que sea más congruente con todo más
realista perfecto y de igual manera si
yo quisiera que dividir este 5 en 5
unidades pues podría caminar cada una de
las unidades para llegar al 5 es decir 1
2 3 4 5 unidades
dejen ponerlas aquí yo puedo dividir del
0 al 5 en 5 unidades y me dan estas de
aquí y así me podría mantener haciendo
esto estas son las escalas lineales y
bueno ya que lo recordamos ahora vamos a
pensar en un nuevo giro en nuestras
escalas qué te parece si queremos llegar
al 10 pero hacemos una manera distinta
así que vamos a hablar de las escalas
logarítmicas y por lo tanto voy a
dibujar aquí mi eje de las escalas
logarítmicas nigel logarítmica y voy a
empezar en lugar del 0 en el 1 y en todo
este vídeo te voy a ir explicando poco a
poco porque empezamos en el 1 y no
empezamos en 0 y bueno la diferencia de
esta escala y de este eje al otro es que
aquí arriba lo que hacíamos era sumar 10
si nos movíamos una misma cantidad esta
distancia de rojo es la misma distancia
que tenemos aquí sin embargo aquí lo que
voy a hacer es multiplicar por 10 en
lugar de sumar lo que voy a ir haciendo
es multiplicando por 10 entonces 1 por
10 llegó al 10 perfecto aquí está el
valor de 10 sin embargo si yo me muevo
la misma distancia otra vez a la derecha
estaría multiplicando otra vez por 10 y
en lugar de llegar al 20 voy a llegar en
esta ocasión al 100 fíjate que la
diferencia es bastante grande lo que
estoy haciendo es una escala mucho mayor
y también para el lado contrario si yo
empiezo en el 100 y lo que hago es
moverme hacia la izquierda lo que voy a
hacer en lugar de multiplicar por 10 es
dividir entre 10 mientras que en la
escala de arriba en él
arriba lo que hacía era restar 10 y de
igual manera si empiezo en el 1
lo que hago es mover nación izquierda lo
que voy a hacer es dividir entre 10 y
voy a llegar al undécimo y si me sigo
moviendo hacia la izquierda en lugar de
llegar al menos 20 lo que voy a hacer es
repetir otra vez entre 10 y voy a llegar
al un centésimo y date cuenta que esta
escala ya es bastante distinta solamente
por multiplicar en lugar de sumar si
nosotros nos movemos dos unidades de
distancia iguales hacia la derecha lo
que estoy haciendo es multiplicando por
10 dos veces déjame ponerlo aquí si yo
de aquí acá me moví dos veces la misma
distancia lo que estoy haciendo
multiplicando 10 por 10 10 por 10 lo
cual me da 10 al cuadrado es decir estoy
multiplicando por 10 elevado al cuadrado
mientras que en el otro lo que estaba
haciendo era sumando 10 + 10 es decir 20
y de igual manera para atrás si yo
empiezo aquí en el 1 y me muevo 2
unidades de distancia e iguales hacia la
izquierda lo que estoy haciendo déjeme
tomar otro color el color morado lo que
estoy haciendo es dividiendo
10 es decir divido entre 10 2 veces
divido entre 10 divido entre 10 que esto
es lo mismo que multiplicar por 1 sobre
100 que dividir entre 100 es exactamente
lo mismo
multiplicar por 1 entre 10 al cuadrado
es decir lo que estoy haciendo es
dividiendo entre 10 y date cuenta que
esta escala es mucho más grande que la
escala que tenemos aquí arriba cuando me
moví dos unidades de distancia iguales a
las que me moví aquí arriba lo que hice
es llegar hasta el 7 mientras que en el
otro llegaba al 20 si te das cuenta el
espectro del de abajo es mucho más
amplio que el espectro del de arriba y
además en las cantidades pequeñas nos
podemos acercar de una manera mucho más
fina y si me muevo una más pues llegaría
hasta el 1000 y se muevo una más pues
llegaría al 10.000 etcétera voy
creciendo bastante rápido y de igual
manera voy disminuyendo bastante rápido
ahora bien hablemos de cantidades fijas
si yo me fijo aquí en el eje que tengo
arriba si yo quiero llegar al 2 lo único
que tengo que hacer es sumar o restar
una cierta cantidad para llegar a este 2
de igual manera si yo quiero ir para
atrás 2 tengo que restar 2 sin embargo
si me pregunto en este mismo eje
en el eje de aquí abajo en donde está el
2 pues la pregunta ya no parece ser tan
sencilla te das cuenta y bueno tal vez
el 12 un poco difícil por ahorita
primero mejor pensemos en el 100 si yo
sea decir dónde está el 100
justo ahorita lo que estaría pensando
realmente es 10 elevado a qué potencia
me da 100 es decir cuántas unidades
tengo que caminar cuántas distancias
iguales tengo que caminar para llegar al
cien o dicho de otra manera de una
manera mucho más matemática 10 elevado a
qué potencia me da 100 y es justo lo que
quiero escribir aquí 10 elevado a la
potencia sin nueva integración es igual
a 100 y bueno si resolvemos esto el
signo de interrogación es igual a 2 o de
otra manera en un lenguaje logarítmico
lo que podría decir es el logaritmo en
base 10 de 100 esto cuánto es igual y
bueno sabemos que la respuesta de esto
es igual a 2 por lo tanto tendría que
caminar dos unidades de esta escala
perfecto ahora si seguimos con la misma
lógica si yo me quisiera preguntar dónde
está el 2 en esta en esta recta numérica
en este eje que tengo aquí lo que tendré
si eres 10 elevado
potencia me da dos o mejor aún el
logaritmo en base diez dedos cuánto es
esto a cuánto equivale así que vamos
sacar la calculadora y lo voy a escribir
aquí el logaritmo recuerda que el log en
la mayoría de las calculadoras
representa el logaritmo en base 10 el
logaritmo de 2 es igual a punto 301
cercano punto 301 así que déjenme
ponerlo aquí esto es cercano a cero
punto 301 que es muy cercano a un tercio
por lo tanto lo que quiere decir es que
si yo tengo esta unidad en la que me
estoy moviendo si de esta misma
distancia yo me tomo 1.301 de esta
distancia voy a llegar al 2 es decir más
o menos es como por aquí porque estamos
hablando que es casi un tercio entonces
voy a suponer que por aquí está el 2 y
déjame ponerlo aquí es más déjeme poner
un poquito más a la derecha para que sea
un poco más creíble aquí está el 2
perfecto es decir estamos a punto 301 de
la unidad que me estoy tomando aquí y si
te das cuenta lo que estoy haciendo es
multiplicando 1 por 2 y si estamos
duplicando uno por 2
entonces ya sé cómo llegar a 4
que si yo camino otra vez esta misma
cantidad voy a llegar a 4 porque 2 x 2
es 4 y de igual manera que podría llegar
a 8 porque 2 por 4 es 8 etcétera y bueno
ya tengo la respuesta de esto con el 2
ahora qué pasa si pensamos en el 5 por
ejemplo bueno si pensamos en el 5 lo que
podremos seres humanos del logaritmo en
base 10 de 5 y ver cuánto es
o tal vez encontrarlo de una manera
mucho más creativa porque si yo lo que
hago es fijarme que aquí tengo ya el 10
en lugar de aplicar la operación
logaritmo si yo camino a la misma
distancia ojo fíjate como es tan
importante esto si yo camino a la misma
distancia del 1 al 2 desde el 10 a la
izquierda pues en lugar de multiplicar
por 2 lo que voy a hacer es dividir
entre 2 recuerda que es la operación
contraria que es difícil entre 2 y 10
entre 2 pues 5 entonces ya con esto aquí
encontraría el valor de 55 estaría como
por aquí y yo espero hacer pronto un
vídeo donde tenga mucho más refinado
este deje un eje mucho más amplio donde
te puedes dar cuenta con más claridad
dónde está cada uno de estos números
pero bueno a ver vamos a preguntarnos lo
siguiente ya que tengo el 5 ya que tengo
el 2 pues dónde está el 3 así que vamos
a cargar en un 10 3
punto 47 7 es decir casi a la mitad si
yo tengo esta distancia y aquí está casi
la mitad entonces por aquí voy a tener
al 3 y bueno entonces la distancia que
hay de aquí acá es multiplicar por 3 y
si yo camino la misma distancia hasta
acá voy a llegar al 9 si la distancia
que hay del 1 al 3 es multiplicar por 3
entonces empiezo en el 3 y camino a la
misma distancia llegó al 9 que es este
de aquí y bueno si yo quiero saber dónde
está el 6 pues tengo que agarrar el 3 y
multiplicarlo por 2 es decir caminar la
distancia que hay del 1 al 2 para ello
llegar al 6 del 3 voy a caminar la misma
distancia que del 1 al 2 y aquí voy a
llegar al 6 y bueno nos falta solamente
el 7 y sus 2 que vamos a ver dónde está
el 7 pues lo que tengo que hacer es
tomarme otra vez el logaritmo en base 10
de 7 o decir qué potencia tengo que
llevarlo al 10 para que me dé 7 y es la
potencia punto 84 5 que está más o menos
por aquí y bueno lo que quiero que te
des cuenta es que en este eje lo que
tenemos es una cantidad fija pero
escalada lo que estamos haciendo
aplicando por una cantidad fija ahora
bien un par de cosas interesantes que
quiero que te des cuenta es cómo está en
el vídeo que hice con bihar donde
contábamos cómo percibimos en objetos la
escala logarítmica que por cierto es una
buena forma de entender cómo lo
percibimos desde un punto humano ahora
seguramente una de las cosas más
extrañas que ves aquí es que los números
muestran su posición original de hecho
hay un gran salto del 1 al 2 después de
un salto un poco menor del 12 al 31
menor del 3 al 4 y como que se van
acumulando cerca del 3 son saltos cada
vez más pequeños y después se van
pegando o acercando al 10 como que se
van pegando se van pegando se van
pegando y se van haciendo más delgados y
más delgados y más delgados hasta llegar
al 10 y de igual manera si nosotros
quisiéramos por ejemplo encontrar el 20
vamos será un salto grande de aquí hasta
acá llegaríamos al 20 si caminamos la
misma distancia que es del 1 al 2 porque
estamos multiplicando el 10 por 2 y me
da 20 este caminamos la misma distancia
que del 1 al 3 vamos a llegar al 30
porque esto es multiplicar por 3
recuerda que esto era por 3 y entonces
empezamos en el 10 y caminamos la misma
distancia que es del 1 al 3
multiplicamos por 3 y llegaríamos hasta
el 30
los saltos se empezarían a disminuir
cada vez más pero afortunadamente espero
que esto te dé un poco más de intuición
de cómo se ve a una recta logarítmica y
por ende cómo se ven los números en la
escala logarítmica y espero que al menos
te dé un poco de precisión de por qué
son útiles